but yeah it's clearly it's like charcoal
it's clearly like a brownish color mhm
wow so folks this this will actually
slay you look at this when we mix all
the colors together we get brown when we
look up Genesis 2:7 and Genesis 3 God
formed Man Out of the Dust of the brown
brown and so Brown is representative as
dirt so look at this this is my
principle humanity is a central focus of
all the wonderful attributes of the
color wheel all of these colors have to
do with God's provision for us is that
beautiful is that amazing so again as a
child that was also struggling with
identity and sexuality issues I didn't
think that God loved me I didn't serve
God because I didn't obey him because I
loved him I obeyed him because I feared
him when we studied these colors with
our children we're now giving them the
principle that God loves you and then he
wants to provide for you all of these
wonderful things so again we're giving
our our children not only principles of
identity and sexuality but what's most
important I think is the fact that we
are not only created by God but Redeemed
by God why because we are the central
focus of everything that he Delights to
give to us
[Music]
wow welcome back to LED live today we
have Michael cardui from coming out
Ministries back in the house Michael
welcome back to our show it's good to be
here we're going to talk about a very
sensitive issue you guys are probably
not unfamiliar with the way our world is
dealing with sexuality and identity but
Michael's here to help us understand
when talking with children um it can be
a very difficult thing when do we do
that what age in you know the world's
pushing their ideas on them so we're
going to kind of discuss how do we
approach this topic and Michael are
people nervous when you bring this topic
up because you speak in schools and
churches and yeah no they're terrified
and when they hear oh the xkay is coming
to our school to teach our children
about the rainbow so of course you know
everyone gets frightened but um I was
asked to actually speak to a school that
had 0 through 12 and kindergarten
through 12 and I didn't have a program
really for young kids but I certainly
couldn't share with them what I share
with the teenagers and unfortunately now
in the world that we're living in if we
wait until our kids are 12 and 13
they've already been spoken to yeah yeah
it's already the world is uh addressing
sexuality and ident even before kids get
into school and so well Blues Clues and
everything too what's that Blues Clues
is talking about it right right right so
the idea then was how can I address this
issue for the younger kids and prepare
them without exposing them or destroying
their innocence and yet also speak to
the kids so we divided them up and I
came up with this program that actually
this little old man that he wasn't
little he was 6'6 that lived in uh this
little town in uh Tennessee that he did
this Bible study about the rainbow and
of course being a hairdresser he did it
in a pyramid so I put it in a circle and
and the Lord has really kind of blessed
me I think with you know it's it's not
necessarily what a theologian would say
is sound Doctrine but I think it makes
sense and I use it as an opportunity to
illustrate to our young children about
what each of the colors in the rainbow
means because now we're afraid of the
rainbow you know nobody talks about the
rainbow because it automatically relates
to a certain you know group of
individuals that have the whole month of
June to celebrate so how is it that we
can take that rainbow back and also
without exposing a certain uh group of
people that I believe have been
marginalized or minimized um but also in
a way where we can Elevate that to our
children to give them a foundation about
identity and sexuality that will help
them that when they're exposed to these
contemporary identities that they at
least have a foundation and it also
increases the opportunity for the parent
and the child to have an established
relationship where they can come and
they can ask real questions and get real
answers because I think it makes sense
that a lot of parents are frightened and
so they just stay away from it and then
unfortunately when the kid is left in
their room you know with the internet
then they are being you know completely
indoctrinated by these issues and the
parents are left wondering what happened
let me give you an example if I could I
mean I I guess I can understand where
some parents would come from because you
know if your kids aren't really exposed
to that kind of stuff or not around that
kind of stuff it's like you don't want
them being peaked in their curios
I think this is very important to talk
so a pastor had called me and we were
talking about doing a program in his
area because he wondered why his
daughter had you know cut her hair and
shaved part of her eyebrow and hung a
gay pride flag in her room and I asked
him I said well you know is does she
have a heart for Spiritual things he
goes oh yeah she does family worship
with the family every night and and I
said well does your daughter have
unlimited access to the internet and he
said well of course I trust that my
daughter you know is mature enough to
know what to look at on the internet and
I said to this man I said there are
50-year-old men that have absolutely no
control over the internet and I said
giving your children unlimited access to
the internet is like giving a razor
blade to a baby you know that's just how
destructive the internet is and how
unfortunate that this pastor was
actually paying for all of this
streaming that come in and his daughter
was being completely indoctrinated by a
completely different world and the
parents didn't even know so as parents
we want to be very cautious with with
how we approach us because yeah we don't
want to plant a seed and then they go
home and you know look stuff up or or
are asking the wrong people so I'm
excited about your uh presentation I
assure you this is not moonshine in this
these are just mason jars and it's water
that's right so what I want to do is
kind of break down a little bit of where
we are and how I developed this program
um so basically who am I is um kind of
like I took out it originally it was uh
In His Image but for people who are
secular that may you know want to
introduce these ID these ideas to
children or whatever without you know
kind of giving credit to a deity or
whatever I think that this is secular
enough to where it's still appealing and
I think when you talk about the rainbow
whatever kind of connects people but
also gives us the opportunity to
introduce some biblical themes that I
think are really valuable for a kid and
it's kind of fun you know so it I call
it who am I uh by coming out Ministries
and it's a five-day program that I give
in schools grade schools and churches
basically going over 5 days of identity
and sexuality for the kids so I actually
uh consulted with some uh educational
leaders from bogenhofen in Austria the
this woman in the middle she actually
has a master's degree in gender studies
and it was interesting in the
conversation that we were having I asked
her I said so what happens in a in a
master's level gender study when you get
to the biology and she said we don't
study biology and she even said
something that that
really I think is just hysterical um
when you think about the context of a
masters in gender studies but she said
that the basic foundation of the whole
master's degree was the fact that there
is no truth so if there is no truth then
it's basically whatever you it's a
freefor all you can make it whatever you
want and because it's called gender
study that terminology that definition
of gender doesn't mean sex or biology
anymore it's more of a emotional they're
redefining it's whatever you create in
your mind right so as I came to together
with this program and as I borrowed the
tools from a man named Bill Barrett who
passed away after he kind of gave me the
foundation for the rainbow um I've
actually used it in Bible studies with
new Believers I was actually at the
Grand Canyon and I was with my my fellow
teammates and it was my turn to do the
devotion so we were doing a study of the
Bible studies and there was a a couple
from Italy that were waiting to go into
the canyon and we invited them and they
were looking up the Bible verses so it
was really fun and interactive you can
use it in multiple different levels but
this one in particular is about relating
to Children especially for parents look
at some of the books that are out there
now this is called Jacob's new dress and
it's interesting because Jacob in the
Bible means deceiver so it's interesting
I'm sure that the uh that the creator of
this book didn't necessarily put that
together but it shows Jacob standing an
address in front of his father you know
and it says there are lots of different
ways to be a boy now for me at four
years old my very first conscious
thought was that I was a girl trapped in
a boy's body so that followed me until I
was 20 years old and for children that
don't know the difference between
fantasy and reality imagine the hook
that this book would have had for
somebody like me here's another book
called my princess boy he says he has a
cool brother and his brother plays
Sports princess boy is the one in the
Tiara and the dress Princess boy has a
cool dad his dad tells him how pretty he
looks in a dress and he takes him by the
hand and he tells him to twirl all of
this is about shaping the minds of pre
you know pre um school kids that
identity and sexuality are completely
fluid and changeable so I live in the
Bible Belt and it is interesting that it
says his dad so it's not they're not
identifying as a girl they're just
crossdressing I think it's just the
introduction that identity is flexible
otherwise you could just think that's a
girl because there it's faceless and all
that it's a great point to make Mike so
yeah living in the Bible Belt um I
thought to myself I was at the Walmart
getting getting tires and I thought well
what does the Bible Belt really offer to
kids about identity and God and look at
this what is God like and the kid looks
normal and it talks about God is like a
mother and the mother looks normal and
God is like a father and the father
looks normal and everything is you know
pretty copesthetic until you get to the
page of what God is like and look at
this God has nose rings and earrings and
is nonbinary and green and purple and
orange hair and and I looked at this
page and I go wow what a subtle way to
introduce the LGBT agenda to our
children so again our our our children
are being addressed on these issues even
before they enter in the school which I
believe it's not enough to basically you
know do Noah's Arc in a cradle roll room
and and have a couple of stuffed animals
look at this in England in the United
Kingdom they had a th% increase this was
5 years ago now it's 3,000% increase so
in 5 years it's gone up
3,000% gender confusion and this isn't
to help little boys to identify as
little boys this is to help assist them
to take the hormone blockers and
eventually they can have the sex changes
by the time they're 14 and 15 years old
and it's gone up
3,000% years we've discussed this and we
say this almost every time that we deal
with this with this particular topic but
this absolutely speaks to what has
changed more representation in the media
all of a sudden we see the effects in
society so I hope and pray if you've
been watching this channel for long
enough that you guys will see what you
watch what you read has a direct imp
influence over absolutely you I just
find it interesting that for all these
years children never had issues with it
and then all of a sudden they do like
where does it come from like you said
it's from the media it's from the
parents and it's from the schools where
and who they hang out with right like
they get an example somewhere do you
know the greatest EX or the greatest
group of people that are affected by
this whole trans movement are adolescent
girls the the spike is exponential among
adolescent girls I think it's because
you know girls are more uh clickish
together and so you know if one girl
says to her girlfriend you know I'm a
lesbian then the other girl is like oh I
commiserate with you well I'll be
bisexual you know or and then what
happens is these group of girls kind of
rally together and and they're like oh
my body's changing I'm having this
monthly cycle I'm getting bumps and
curves where I didn't expect it and so
there is a lot of transitioning hormones
that are going on that are causing a lot
of girls to say wait wait wait I'm not
ready for this I don't want that and so
of course the trans movement is real
appealing to a young girl that's you
know bracing um puberty and that kind of
thing so it's a huge uh Spike but they
have done studies and they found that 80
to 95% of gender dysphoric girls if they
don't if they aren't moved towards the
hormones and the surgeries by the time
they're in their mid-20s they're
completely identifying in their biology
as a female so it's interesting that in
over 20 States in our in our country
that it's illegal to counsel an
adolescent a minor that they could
actually be comfortable in their biology
you can only refer them to gender
clinics and to put them on the hormones
but this is Paul waser and he makes this
incredible statement he says your
children will go to public school and
they will be trained for somewhere
around 15,000 hours in ungodly secular
thought and then they'll go to Sabbath
school and they'll color a picture of
Noah's Arc and you think that that's
going to stand against the lies that
they are being told this is the world in
which we're living in how can we protect
our children against the onslaught of
this LGBT movement without
um in my opinion pointing out a group of
people or causing more questions about
identity and sexuality and of course
that's why we came up with In His Image
or you know who am I right so what I've
done is I put together this kind of
water color thing that we use with food
coloring you know and you can do this
demonstration at home we do it in the
churches in the schools the kids love to
mix the colors and Mikey I think you're
going to really enjoy your part in this
whole presentation um I came up with a
um with this graph that you can use and
you can take a screenshot of that and
have that printed out for your kids to
color in as we go through this um we're
going to do a separate program for the
kids right which isn't going to be
filled with all of this information that
we're giving to the parents um so the
idea is is that you can watch this to
understand what we're going to be
presenting to your children um and we're
going to talk about the issues but
you're going to see I think the value
and the benefit of what this program can
really do for our kids so again I did it
with my grand niece on a Sabbath
afternoon look at how cute she colored
all of that in um I take this to Sabbath
schools and as we go through the
different colors look at how the
children just Delight to hold up their
Pages we have the older kids help out
the younger kids so there's really no
age limit on it then for the children's
story I have actually have the children
tell the parents what each of the colors
mean in the rainbow and it's really
powerful it's really powerful so it's a
great thing to have in our churches
coming out Ministries our vision
statement is to ignite an unquenchable
movement restoring all men and women
back to the image
of our Creator God that's not a gay
thing or a straight thing it's really
about restoring us back to who we were
When sin came along back in Genesis so
from Genesis to Revelation it's about
bringing us back into the image of our
creator which I think is the issue
that's being under attack right now the
image of God and I love the that your
guys's logo I mean just has so much like
to it that you're running to Jesus and
that's really the answer right um I mean
there's there's all kinds of messes of
things that we could get ourselves
involved in and and and unfortunately in
today's world we've put this like kind
of crowning sin upon homosexuality and
things but we all deal with all variety
of different things and so um just if
anybody's watching this and and it's
like why you guys always hammering on
this it's like no we we we we feel very
much so we have a lot of issues that we
need to deal with as well just even
outside of the the topic of
homosexuality but Jesus is the answer I
mean he's the only one that's going to
get us out of any of these messes so
hopefully when you understand this topic
and you frame it within the context of
of of Jesus that will help you immensely
right so Scotty well I think it needs to
be talked about because it's becoming so
acceptable and it's no not other sins
aren't like that like well it's okay if
you're a liar embrace it you know it's
okay that you commit adultery keep doing
it that's you but this it's like no this
sin is okay you should embrace it and
keep running with it well that's what's
happened is we've made exclusive certain
behaviors or certain certain sins that
the Bible defines very clearly and when
you make a group of people exclusive and
I think of 1 Corinthians 6 and: 11 it
says such were some of you meaning you
used to belong to that group but you
don't anymore because you've been washed
you've been uh Sanctified and Justified
those are things that only the power of
God can do I can't do that for myself
but when you make a group of people
exclusive because you love them you're
now cutting them off from the
transforming power of what Jesus did on
the cross so that's not a message of
Love really ultimately is it so coming
up Ministries we're not really about the
issue of just one particular issue we're
about all issues from abortion divorce
uh pornography masturbation premarital
sex as well as the LGBT issu so um we're
representing I think what is the
complete picture of 1 Corinthians
chapter 6: 9 and 10 so again we're not
picking on any one group of people but
we believe that God wants to address
these issues and not have us just
pretend they don't exist or wash it
under the rug until our kids get old
enough to where they're completely
indoctrinated and cut off from even
wanting to know about you know Godly
principles so when I'm standing in front
of the kids and they're all gathered
together I ask them I go am I a giraffe
and they go no am I of a zebra no dog
cat and I talk about how wonderful these
animals are and the attributes that they
have but of course the kids know this
principle very easily and I go what am I
and you know nothing short of you're an
old bald man they all say just a human
and I go that's right I'm a human and we
take them to Genesis 1 and verse 27
girls and boys are what we are and then
I do this this exercise with the kids
because kids love to move and you know
we want to keep them active so I ask
them I go if you're a boy stand up and
of course the boys jump up and I go if
your boy jump up and down and the boys
jump up and down and they make a lot of
noise and you know they're cracking up
or whatever and I go all right if your
boy sit down if your girl stand up and
then the girl stand up and I go if your
girl Spin and the girl start spinning
and all of this is just a very simp
simple illustration to den know the
differences between boys and girls
that's right that's right so the you
know the kids understand this principle
very easily we're demonstrating that God
only made two kinds male and female a
very simple um principle we talk about
creation about how God spoke and the
whole universe was created on every day
at the end of creation God stood back
and he said this is good but on the day
that he created Adam and Eve he didn't
just speak it he used his hands because
he's an intimate God and he formed man
out of the D to the ground and he
breathed into his nostrils a holy kiss
and Man became a living soul and so we
talk about the fact that on Friday when
God created Adam and Eve he stood back
and he said this isn't just good this is
very good and what was so good about it
was the fact that this was the image of
God created in one man and one woman
talking about the fact that again that
God made every boy to be a father and
every girl to be a mother and God
created us that way with this beautiful
special gift so marriage was created in
the Garden of Eden and the first work
that he gave him he said be fruitful and
multiply and so how beautiful God only
made two kinds but that's where we get
mothers and fathers brothers and sisters
sons and daughters so all of that was
established in the Garden of Eden and
again between two created beings male
and female you know I got
married two months ago in a in a few
days well then this lesson is really
good
for um and and you know like I I was
just realizing like man there's so much
Beauty in a marriage between a man and a
woman and I was I was sleeping next to
my husband I was looking at him and I
was like I could never imagine you know
being with a woman because it's not how
God designed it it would be so different
and and just seeing how God created his
beautiful entity of marriage right and
putting two people together from two
different walks of life and and then
that you can then Express God's love in
marriage to each other I frequently will
you know experience God's love through
love of my husband and that's amazing
that is so powerful and how God said
this was very good when he made it and
and I love the differences that God has
because being married as well like there
are different roles that fulfill
different things I mean like as a man
your strength is needed in certain areas
here open this jar yeah do this right
lift this thing there are actual real
tangible things that my wife has a very
difficult time to to do and it's it's
very helpful man and you know it's very
helpful for me to have a wife that tells
me everything that I need to do and all
the details that need to get done right
because I you know men are probably less
into all the connectiveness they're more
one one one track you got a mattress on
the floor and a TV and a Xbox or
whatever but a woman comes in and it's a
home yeah best illustration I saw this
circuit board one time that just had uh
uh uh two switches on it an on and an
off and then there was like a switch
board with like knobs and buttons and
levers and all this kind stuff it's like
this is a man this is a woman it's like
but those differences help make it
something beautiful and those two things
come together and and you know when you
have two of the same thing you miss out
on the blessing I think that God
designed this to be in his context
interesting I was uh we were reading a
book together about marriage the
Christian marriage and the Christian
home and and the one thing that really
stood out to me where it says that the
purpose of the woman is to soften the
man's heart
and the purpose of the man is to cherish
his wife that's beautiful that is
amazing so we have some beautiful
details but again going back to the fact
that God has given one man and one woman
the ability to create life which is a
huge thing so when a father looks into
his baby's face and she says wow she's
got my eyes and when a mother looks into
the baby's face and says wow he's got my
nose God has given us the the amazing
opportunity to know what it's like to be
a Creator and I love it that you can't
do that outside of the context of God
yeah you cannot create that outside of
the way that God designed it well but
science has shown we can do Petri dishes
and test tubes and but you're still
taking yeah you still got to take two
two of the elements of God's creation
and mix them together but I do believe
the science has distorted that beautiful
gift between one male and one female
yeah yeah so anyway now we want to talk
about the fact that we were made lower
than the angels and the kids understand
this I love I love when I can get the
kids to tell me the story rather than me
telling them because it's an affirmation
for them that not only do they know it
but also that the principles are theirs
and that they come up with the ideas so
I asked them and I talk to them about
how God is the creator then we have the
Angels then man and then the kids all
say and then the animals are underneath
man I go yeah that's right so then we
talk about the fact that you know
Lucifer was a fallen angel that became
Satan so Lucifer is an angel and I asked
him did God give the Angels the ability
to create life and they say no oh and of
it's very interesting so they understand
this principle we know that the devil
wanted to be God and he was kicked out
of heaven for you know causing this big
disruption in heaven about that but we
know that the devil wants to be like God
and so imagine how jealous that the
devil is when God bypassed the angels
and gave man the ability to create life
right so we know that the devil came to
do three things he came to steal to kill
and to destroy and without telling our
children about the LGBT is or
transgender or whatever that we are now
giving our children the principle that
the devil is going to try to attack this
precious gift between one man and one
woman so the devil is jealous that we
have this gift that is like God so we
want to tell our children that they have
to protect this gift we haven't talked
to them about LGBT or transgender
anything we just told them about the
gift that God has given to one man and
one woman in a creative relationship and
that the devil is jealous that's all
we've done so now in the next day we
talk about how everyone is unique each
one of us have a fingerprint and we have
the kids all show their fingerprints and
I ask the kids I go can you change your
fingerprint and the kids say no and I go
raise your hand if you don't think you
can change your fingerprint and most of
the hands go up and I go raise you raise
your hand if you think you can and of
course not many of them if any of them
raise her hand but you know something
God uses everything for his glory when I
was 6 years old my mother told me not to
take the Glass glasses outside and I did
and so I broke it and so I was trying to
clean it up before my mother saw it and
I cut open my finger my fingertip right
and so I have 11 stitches that went
right through my middle finger and so I
can change my fingerprint and so when I
show the kids and I have to show each
one of them you know that I cut myself
and they see the scar they start to
realize I can change the outside right
but then we start talking about our DNA
biology we have a fingerprint that's on
the inside and that fingerprint on the
inside is our DNA our DNA is a special
formula a recipe that's unique for every
individual ual there's no one else with
your DNA but God only made two kinds of
DNA male and female so while I can
change the outside while I can change my
fingerprint I cannot change the inside
so without destroying their innocence
we've now let them know that even in a
transgender world I can change the way I
look and some people are very effective
about that but I cannot change the
inside if we give our children that
principle then for a child that is
confused like I was I would understand
that wait a minute I may be able to
appear as the opposite sex but I never
can change that and I think that that's
a really important life lesson for a lot
of D transitioners that have attempted
to mutilate their bodies to cut off
their breast to have hysterectomies or
to have vaginoplasties where they take
their male genitalia and mutilate it
then all of a sudden they start to
realize I cannot change my gender so
imagine how powerful this lesson would
be to a child that's really confused
like me you know when I was four years
old I thought that I was a girl this
info wasn't readily available you no no
no but fortunately they didn't have the
laws to protect children like me either
at that time but now they do and so we
want to be able to help our children if
they're confused about their identity
where this starts and I don't think that
we can wait until our kids are in six
and seventh grade or even third grade so
this was really powerful for me because
I needed to know that God only made two
kinds so now it's a good time to do that
illustration again boys stand up girls
stand up girls spin boys jump so when
you do it's just another uh exercise
teaching our children that that God made
only two kinds male and female I needed
to know this lesson because I was called
queer little girl I never fit in I
felt inadequate as a boy so that only
drove this ideology in my mind that if
I'm worthless as a boy then I need to be
a girl so that was only fueling this
this thought inside my head that I was
in the wrong sex so now we want to talk
about the fact that as a boy stand up
that God made all kinds of males right
but he only made males and females and
so you could be a macho man or you can
be a gentleman does it make me less of a
boy if I like to play an instrument no
does it make me less of a boy if I don't
like sports absolutely not because I'm a
male because that's how God made me so
for a child that may be more feminine
for a child that might be more
aggressive or whatever it's important to
address bullying at the base levels
because for a child like me I needed to
know that I was okay as a boy because I
felt inadequate that was driving me to
think that I need needed to be something
else because it certainly didn't fit in
this way all right so then we talk about
the differences for girls you can be a
girly girl or you can be a sporty girl
does it make you less of a girl if you
like short hair and climbing trees
absolutely not why because you're a girl
does it make you less of a girl if you
like to cook in the kitchen you know
those are many ways there are many ways
to be a girl so the idea is that that we
need to celebrate our girls one of the
things that is the most damaging that in
the 13 years of this ministry that I've
experience is when a mother says to a
boy don't hold your hand like that that
looks like a girl you know when a father
says to the mother oh you finally got
the girl you've always wanted in your
son those simple statements or even you
know stand up don't stand like that
because boys don't do that or Boys Don't
Cry that's right or or even you know for
girls you know um like you know you need
to wear that dress or you need to do
this or whatever what we're doing is
we're criticizing a spirit of our
children when the opposite would be much
more beneficial it's like wow Johnny
that was really good you're such a
strong young man and you know when you
see a feminite mannerisms in your kid
not to criticize and point those out but
rather than to to look for opportunities
where you can embellish them as
masculine and as male that is much more
powerful and and I've seen that not only
exemplified in my life my dad took me
out shooting guns and attack training
German Shepherds and all of that was
just aggressive behavior my mother gave
me pornography magazines when I was 10
thinking that that would help me when I
looked at the these beautiful women and
I thought well if men love them I want
to be loved so I should look like them
so my parents totally went way overboard
um when imagine the power if my dad
would have just colored in a coloring
book with me you know on the dining room
you know table so there are ways that we
can affirm our boys as boys and girls as
girls rather than to criticize them and
make them feel inadequate and rejected
but I think a lot of parents really
don't understand the power of their own
words Bible says a have the power of
life and death so when a parent
criticizes a child because they're not
measuring up to what your expectation is
that criticism can actually be uh what's
the word adverse it can actually push
him even further into that identity I
remember as my father was Critical with
me because I wasn't the boy that he
expected you know that only pushed me
even further to think that I'll never be
what you want me to be so you know what
I'm not going to be anything that you
are so so there is power in that so even
in the home that's demonstrated let
alone the attack on the LGBT issue and
and the agenda but some of those people
in that um Community which I was for
over 20 years you know there was a
defensiveness about that because I had
been criticized for so long from my
earliest memories beginning with my
father and then the kids in school so
there is some unresolved something
that's definitely you know being
manifested at us and and I think that as
Christians if we can understand at least
where that comes from we can be less
offended by that and at least recognize
it for what it is that it's a it's a
history of deep rejection and and
insulting that that has really created I
think the environment that it is but it
is a proper point to make that if you
don't want to be judged then don't judge
me either right but that makes sense so
now this we're getting to the fun part
this is this is like maybe my favorite
part so we talk about how kids love to
dress up now my nephew he was 3 years
old and he loved Samson and my sister
got this really ugly synthetic wig that
that was long and he would put that wig
on and she found a shirt that had
muscles that were built into it and this
little guy would like walk around the
house with that muscle shirt on in that
ugly synthetic Tangled Up wig and he
would take the sofa cushion off the sofa
and he'd walk around the house and he
go like this acting like Samson right so
at the end of the day he would put the
sofa cushion away and take off the shirt
and that ugly wig and and he was you
know my nephew again but you know he had
fun pretending and children God has
given to children well ad an incredible
imagination that's right but children
don't know the difference between
reality and fantasy and so when we are
playing with our children and dressing
up you know we want to encourage their
imagination but again you know at the
end of the day what do you do with your
costume well we put it away right and we
become Little Johnny or little Alice
again and so you know we want to talk
about the fact that it's fun to pretend
and we're giving our children a really
beautiful um um principle here talking
about how how we appear has an influence
in people and sometimes we can really
get kind of caught up in the appearance
of how we are I talk about this dog this
is my dog Bo and he passed away a few
years ago but uh this dog just showed up
when I moved to the to the mountains of
Tennessee and he's part chow and part
golden retriever so you can see that
dog's got a lot of fur and so every year
I would shave him and every year he
would bite me while I would shave him
but being a hairdresser for 30 years one
time I decided to get a little creative
with my dog and so I wanted to give him
a costume and so then I show the kids my
costume that I gave to my
dog and the kids just squeal they just
sque with theight that is so cool and I
asked him I go does he look like a lion
they go yes and I go but is he lion and
they go no and so the kids understand
that that how we appear makes a
difference to what people see and so um
the highest compliment that I got is
that somebody actually reported in East
Tennessee that they saw a lion no way
yeah yeah yeah so it was the highest
compliment so then we want to talk about
about the fact that in the Bible there
are many people that put on costumes and
I asked the kids to come up with
different ideas and depending on the age
level of the kids and how much they've
been exposed to to Bible studies they
they come up with amazing stories they
talk about how you know uh Satan put on
a a snake costume about how Satan put on
an angel of Light costume and then I ask
the kids I go were their costumes
effective and some of the costumes were
very effective Jacob disguised himself
as his brother and it worked Leah
disguised herself as her sister Rachel
and it worked so wait you're telling me
that the entire wedding she didn't say a
word and Jacob didn't go this doesn't
sound like Rael like and that Veil must
have been a tablecloth you know couldn't
even see through that could have been a
dude under there so I asked the kids I
asked the kids I go was the costume
effective was the disguise effective and
sometimes it's yes and sometimes it's
NOS no when um um Samuel or no when Saul
went to the The Witch of Endor he
disguised himself right and I say was
his disguise effective no because she
understood who she knew who he was and
then I said was their disguise a good
thing or a bad thing and so the kids
have to answer that question and most of
the time it was a bad thing we even use
the example of Jesus walking to uh uh
what was it he was walking toas yes the
road to amas with the uh with the
different disciples and I said was it
costume effective and they go yeah for a
while but when he broke the bread they
recognized who he was and I said was
this costume a good thing or a bad thing
it was a good thing so we talk about how
costumes can be a good thing or a bad
thing and this is the principle that
principle that we're giving them because
I think that this is a really difficult
principle to address with our kids but
God is very clear that he wants boys to
look like boys and girls to look like
girls and I ask the kids like go why
what's the big deal and the kids say it
so quickly they go because it's
confusing and so they understand this
principle and because we've used the dog
and then the stories of the Bible and
the different costumes we've now shown
our children that it's fun to pretend it
doesn't change who we are but it's
important God says that boys need to
dress as boys and girls as girls so
here's an interesting question for you
is it wrong to wear a dress for a guy
mhm I think depends on the culture
because there's some cultures where men
wear dresses exactly and their different
than the women in Bible times if you
ever look at you know that they were
wearing like long dresses basically
right but it didn't look like a female
dress yeah I believe if they upheld
upheld the biblical principle where it
says you know a man should not put on a
woman's clothing and vice versa they
absolutely would have had different
robes like a man's robe a woman's robe
and so so so the point of that really
was is the the the imagery is is there
to illustrate um is this a male is this
a female it's not necessarily the design
of the clothing if you would it's it's
also does do women wear this and do men
wear this can tell the difference in a
blouse and a man's T-shirt or a woman's
jeans and men's jeans I mean even though
they're the same they're different well
and God didn't say that men can't wear
dresses it just says that men shouldn't
wear women's garments so even in that
would make people think that they're are
the opposite in Scotland men wear kilts
you know that would look like a skirt
but yet that is specifically a design
you know for men so it's important to to
point that out recently I was trying to
hurry up in the morning to get to work
and I and I was like I can't find this
shirt that I want to wear and my husband
was like just wear my white shirt said I
literally said no that looks like a
man's shirt his shirt is way differently
shaped than my shirt would be and I
didn't feel like it was appropriate for
me to go to work wearing his shirt so so
this is really interesting and I'm only
bringing this up in the context of what
we're talking with parents about but um
there was a movie called the Danish girl
and it was a story of one of the first
transgender people and it happened at
the turn of the century uh he was an
artist married to an artist and there
was a situation and he was holding on to
his identity he was really trying to you
know to be the man even though he had
these these unresolved thoughts and
feelings and attractions and in the
movie she needs somebody to wear the
dress of the ballerina that she was
painting and the model was gone so she
says to her husband she goes listen you
know I need to finish this painting you
know just sit here for an hour and he
goes I'm not putting that dress on she
goes no you don't have to she said but
put the hose and the shoes on so you see
him putting the hose and the shoes on
and you see something clicking in the
back of his mind and he refuses to wear
the dress she just takes a dress and she
puts it on him and as she puts it on him
he has to hold the dress but as she's
painting away you see something happen
to him and this is exactly what happened
to me as a little boy when I would put
on my sister's or my mother's clothes
there was this click there was this
disconnect there was this reattachment
or this this this leaving my identity
that I was very unhappy in to the
fantasy that that I could actually be
considered something else and as you see
this man touching the the lace and the
silk of that beautiful dress and as he's
looking at his legs in the the hose and
those shoes there was a transformation
that was happening so I use this as an
illustration that even when you take
your little brother and you dress him up
as a girl when he's two or three years
old and he prances around the house and
everybody giggles and squeals with the
lights you are breaking something very
powerful to God because you don't know
the power like Scotty you'd be okay in
that dress be all right but for me that
would have been transformative and
that's why God says it's important that
boys were boy clothes and girls were
girl clothes because you have no idea
the power of what you're setting in
motion when you allow to crossdress and
to cross over on these things when my
brother and I were teenagers um or
actually probably early teenagers years
um we would fly my parents lived in two
sides of California Southern and
Northern so when we'd fly to my mom's
house we flew over Halloween one time
and um we dressed up as Bill and Hillary
Hillary Clinton and of course my older
brother was Bill I was Hillary so I
actually wore a dress on an airplane
with a mask on and they made us hand out
the peanuts I thought that was hilarious
what yeah but I'll tell you what I I
never felt like Hillary ever actually
you know was like I was couldn't wait to
get that thing off wow so it's
interesting using that that kind of
theme I remember when I first came out
into the gay culture I still had this
thought in my head that I was inadequate
as a male and that I needed to be a
female and even as a Christian I thought
that the perfect solution was that if I
have a sex change then my same sex
attraction would be okay with God
perfect solution everybody's happy but I
remember when I was 20 years old and my
sister helped dress me up she did my
makeup I put on her dress I got hose and
everything like that and I was wearing
this outfit something clicked for me in
that moment and even though I was
finally fulfilling my fantasy of being
in public and wearing this dress in
these women's clothing like throughout
that night the sad reality was is that I
had chest hair that I had to cover I had
to wear fish necks that cover my leg
hair I had very muscular calves so
didn't really look natural in those
heels and so that was a reality for me
that I didn't fit in there but for many
men they use that as an example in
public to to dress in Halloween or to
crossdress is very powerful for these
individuals that they can finally
Express what's been repress for many
years but I think at the end of the day
it's still an illusion because I've seen
enough interviews I've seen enough
testimonies of people that have gone
through either transitional periods or
done the surgeries or whatever and they
keep saying the same thing I would do
this one more thing thinking that this
was if I just take off the breast I will
feel like a woman they take it or a man
they take it off don't feel like a man
every time you look in the mirror you
still are that person that you know I'm
not a female I'm a I'm a male or vice
versa right and isn't it interesting
that when man sinned what was the first
thing that they wanted to do cover put
something on that made them feel feel a
certain way right so yes our our our
clothing has a huge impact Upon Our
psychology of where we're at but we know
from the story of Adam and Eve you can
try to cover yourself it will never be
with the same as what Jesus covers Us
and and and his robe of righteousness is
what we want and isn't it interesting
because it was Satan that was the first
one to cover himself in something that
wasn't true to who he was so the point
that I want to make as you said it was
um a delusion right I said I said it's
just a a a um uh like the word I use was
a perfect word yeah it was a an illusion
it may have been an illusion but there's
power behind that illusion because when
a man that struggles with identity
issues puts on a woman's blouse or puts
on a woman's dress or puts on women's
makeup there is a power that a lot of
people don't realize that is actually
happening um Walt h a famous D
transitioner he talks about the fact
that his grandmother dressed him up as a
little girl girl for the first seven
years of his life and that was what
planted that seed I'm inadequate as a
boy I need to be celebrated as a girl
and that's the power of what that did
even though it was an illusion it still
had a lot of power and I think the
parents really don't understand this
principle because you know maybe for you
Scotty that didn't have any power but to
somebody like me it was huge and so now
we're getting to one of the most
exciting parts and we're talking about
Noah and the Ark so when we bring up
Noah and the Ark we talk about Genesis 6
ver5 where the world was wicked and that
God basically had to start over but we
want to be compassionate we want to
represent God always as compassionate
and I asked the kids well how many
people did God want to get on the ark
everyone right but only eight people got
on the ark so in the process of talking
about the story we knew know that it
wasn't just Noah and his family that got
on the ark it was also the animals and
so how many of the animals and the kids
say two of every kind and then some of
the smart alet kids they go seven of the
clean animals and I go wow that's pretty
good right so then they go two of every
animal and they go what two boy animals
of every kind or two girl animals of
every kind and the kids say no and I go
why and they go because they need to
have babies and so how beautiful when
the kids actually tell me the truth you
know because then that's an affirmation
that not only do they know the
information but they basically
understand the concept and then they're
reinforcing it for themselves because
they corrected me so anyway yeah it's a
beautiful opportunity and and um we talk
about the fact that there wouldn't be
animals in our Earth today if two of
every animal did not get on the Ark of M
one male and one female so it's a
beautiful way to affirm the principle
with our children that God's design is
one male and one female so then we talk
about the fact that no and his wife got
on the ark as well as his sons and I say
did anybody else get on the ark and of
course the kids say they're wives and I
go why why would God need their wives to
get on the ark as well and again the
kids shout out the principal so they can
have babies like I'm an idiot and I go
that's right so you know would we be
here if you know no and his wife and his
sons and their wives didn't get on the
ark and of course the answer is no so we
we've now affirmed not only through the
creation story but now also through Noah
the animals on the ark Noah and his
family we're affirming again that male
and female is God's design so now we
want to take our kids to the zoo or to
the farm and we ask the kids you know
what does it take to make a baby chick
and the kids of course say a rooster and
a h
understanding the differences between
the male species and the female species
and what does it take to make a baby
calf it takes a a bull and a heer to
different kinds of the same kind to make
a baby so what's really amazing is um a
lot of times inner city kids really
don't understand this principle and they
really do need an opportunity to go to a
zoo or to a farm to see the differences
in the male species and the female
species as well so now we talk about the
fact that God cover this guy with the
rainbow and this is where it gets kind
of you know I I think a lot of Christian
parents are really apprehensive to talk
about the rainbow you know and want to
you know hide it away or whatever but
Rainbows are such an integral part of
our world and our society today
especially around the month of June well
so crazy when I grew up I saw the
rainbow all the time like in in Bible
class A Bible book you always see Noah
in the big rainbow and I knew the
rainbow is a promise that God won't
destroy the world again and it was a
beautiful thing you'd have crafts of
making the rainbow and there was no
Stigma to it back then right but now
we're afraid because we think that if we
study the Bible we're going to direct
our children towards these contemporary
identities and sexuality that we're
wanting to protect them from and in my
opinion what we're doing was we're
setting them them up for failure because
we haven't given them the proper
Principle as a foundation so that when
they you know see the other rainbows
that they that they'll be confused about
that so I believe that if we study these
that we can actually help guide our
children and give them a foundation so
that they can count the colors of the
the rainbow let me be just very
Elementary because I'm 63 and I didn't
understand the difference I didn't know
that God's rainbow actually has seven
colors wow did you know that I did
that's I actually had to look it up on
the internet and make sure that rainbow
has the Roy G Biv thing it's it's it's
exactly that I wish I would have known I
would have known then that there were
seven colors but you know what we're not
going to talk about all seven colors to
start with we're going to talk about the
six colors of the color wheel so these
are the primary and the secondary colors
so we want to start with this we're
going to start talking with the primary
colors because the primary colors are
the three colors that make up all the
colors in our world today and so that's
why they are the primary colors because
without these colors we can't make any
colors our world would be black and
white primary there is no colors that
you can mix together to make that color
that's right that's right that's cool
yeah yeah so now we do a Bible study and
there was a gentleman his name was Bill
Barrett and he passed away a couple of
years ago he lived in a barn that was
converted into his house and he was the
first one that basically did this this
study with me and so I've taken a lot of
his information and kind of put it
together a little bit differently but um
I have to give it the credit to this man
and it really helped to open up my my
eyes that wow God even cares about the
colors of the rainbow and that the
colors are actually talked about in the
Bible That's So Awesome Isn't that cool
so blue when we look up blue we find
that in numbers it talks about the the
ribbon of blue around the Hem of the
high priest garment was to remind them
of the law so if you would go ahead and
fill our blue which is right here this
one yes
okay you know while Mikey is doing that
I just want to point out to the parents
that all you need is just basic food
coloring and and it comes usually with
these four colors but if you're really
good parents you want to take out the
green and you actually want to show your
kids and mix these colors themselves so
what I did is I went ahead of time and I
put the proper drops of of red and
orange and all the different colors in
there and you want to be careful because
every set of food colorings is actually
formulated a little bit different than
any others so I've taken the time to
formulate what will actually make the
correct colors here and you want to make
sure that too but a lot of times I like
to actually mix the colors in front of
the kids if I have time and watch the
kids stir the colors and create the
colors so they can actually see what
happens when you start mixing these
colors but first we want to start off
with the blue and in Ezekiel it talks
about the fact that um the the uh the
stone that the that the Throne of God
was on was this beautiful blue sapphire
stone and then it goes on and it talks
about how the law is God's character so
we start to find these attributes that
that blue represents God's law or his
character it's his throne uh the law is
Holy it's our Liberty and our freedom
it's unchangeable therefore it's
Dependable meaning that we can depend on
it because it doesn't change so parents
if you know anything else that will
actually help to affirm this use it
celebrate it practice it with your
children so that your children know that
the blue has a very distinctive meaning
and a purpose so as we study these um
our children also start to find out the
principles and and we're going to come
to a really excellent conclusion but if
you do know anything that a affirms the
blue as as the law of God and the father
then I think that those are really
beautiful things to bring in what color
is a policeman's outfit oh blue
interesting that was interesting very
cool oh all right all right so hang on a
second I got something else to add to
that so now we want to find out what it
takes to make red if you would fill that
one for us
Mikey so red again is a primary color
that we can't mix that together to get
these colors but when we look in Second
Kings we find that the river was red as
blood and and we know that blood was
also taken from the lamb the lamb
represents Jesus so these are the
attributes of red it's the blood it's
the lamb it's righteousness forgiveness
Redemption and Perfection so we know
that red represents God the son Jesus
that's right that's right so it's
interesting now that we've discovered
two of the colors we want to find out
what the yellow means so in Psalm 6813
it says that the dove had wings of
yellow gold so Mikey if you would this
one all right so we also find out that
yellow represents the Holy Spirit we
know that the attributes of the Holy
Spirit are love hope comfort and Truth
therefore yellow represents God the holy
spirit so here we have our primary
colors which represent the godhead you
mentioned something um off camera about
a dove in the Bible that actually had
the wings of yellow yellow gold in
Psalms never heard that before that's
cool I know right and so as we allow the
word of God to tell us what the meaning
of these colors mean we're not only
giving our children the principles but
we're also claiming back the fact that
God gave us the rainbow not just to
brighten the sky or to remind us of the
promise but also that each color
represents Something Heavenly or
something thing you know that that God
has given to us through the colors so
now that we discovered that the primary
colors the most important colors that
make up all the colors of the rainbow
represent the godhead we want to find
out what happens when I take the
attributes of the Holy Spirit which is
love hope comfort and truth and I mix it
with God the Father which is The Ten
Commandments What color do we get Mikey
go ahead and fill this one if you would
we find that the color that we get is
green green that's right in the Bible
when we look up Psalms 52 and vers 8 in
Jeremiah 17 and: 7 we find that green
represents trust mercy and hope when we
keep the law of God which is blue and we
claim the Holy Spirit which is yellow we
get trust mercy and hope that kind of
makes my mind explode a little bit
because you know knowing that the law is
unchangeable and dependable I can trust
God the mercy of the love hope and
comfort and truth of the holy spirit
means that I can have trust and mercy
and Hope isn't that amazing there's a
lot of benefits to Green as well I know
like when you go out into nature and
you're surrounded by Green it has this
very like healing and calm effect right
I mean you just think about that in in a
psychological sense but also like if
that's really what's offered to you
trust mercy and hope that's a very
caling effect if you really trust
someone you are not anxious and and
things like that so you know even in the
colors you can see how they they tie
into our psychology as well Scotty
there's no end to how far you can take
this so parents as you're talking about
these colors just a simple comment like
that getting your kids to even say what
else does green represent what else do
we have green in our world you know and
you can do this at the breakfast table
you can do it at the dinner table
broccoli is green what does broccoli
represent oh Mom and Dad broccoli is the
trust mercy and hope when you know when
you do the blueberries and the bananas
you know all of this is a beautiful way
to help your children to understand
these principles and to celebrate them
in our regular life every day kids love
repetition and you can actually use the
colors to basically affirm God's um
provision for each one of us amen so
let's keep going so when we take the uh
the law of God which is The Ten
Commandments with the uh blood of Jesus
which was the blood of the Lamb we get
purple so fill this one Michael Mikey if
you would we get the color purple so
when we mix blue and red together we get
the color purple when we look up Judges
chapter 8:26 and Mark 15:17 and 18 we
find that purple was reserved for
royalty only kings and queens could wear
purple and Mark chapter 15 talks about
when Jesus was with Pontius Pilate how
they covered him in a purple robe and
they called him King of the Jews um we
know that royalty was reserved for the
Kings so it's interesting when we keep
the law of God and we claim the blood of
Jesus we now are adopted into the family
of God therefore we are now royalty we
are related to the king therefore we are
entitled not only to protection but also
to an inheritance and what's our
inheritance as children of God eternal
life eternal life Hallelujah so how
beautiful that now our kids understand
keeping the law which is unchangeable
independable claiming the blood of Jesus
which was already sacrificed for us
means that we are adopted we are princes
and princesses and we are all in the
kingdom of God and we are now entitled
to protection and the kingdom of God and
Peter also says that we are uh adopted
into his family as the royal priesthood
come on see excellent this should be
included thank you for that
all right so now we want to find out
what happens when we uh claim the Holy
Spirit which is love hope comfort and
truth and we claim the blood of Jesus
which is our righteousness forgiveness
Redemption and Perfection help us find
out what color we get what color do we
get orange we get the color orange such
a nice orange isn't that pretty you can
start to see the reflection of all these
colors in front of the jars so orange is
actually not in the Bible which would
make me sad if the word amber wasn't
there but am Amber is there and Amber
represents orange when we look up uh
these verses we find that Amber
represents Fire and Fire when we look up
the attributes of fire we find that fire
represents light power Faith praise
honor and Glory so when you claim the
blood of Jesus and the power and Truth
and Love and comfort of the Holy Spirit
we get power over sin Faith praise honor
and glory is that amazing is amazing so
now we've discovered our six colors and
when we discover what these primary and
secondary colors mean remember our
primary colors are the blue which is God
the Father which is The Ten Commandments
red which is God the son which is the
blood of Jesus the blood of the Lamb
yellow represents the um Holy Spirit
right the wings of the dove and that is
love hope comfort and truth so these are
the primary colors but the secondary
colors are green which is trust mercy
and hope purple which is royalty or
inheritance and protection and orange
which is light fire power praise honor
Andor Glory so we've discovered now the
primary and the secondary colors um now
we're going to need that empty jar that
you have behind you if you would we want
to find out and and if you would put
that in front where people can see that
actually I'm going to have Scotty mix
these colors if you would Scotty I just
want you to pour a little bit of each of
these colors that we already have mixed
into that jar to find out what happens
now anyone that ever played just a
little bit because remember you have to
fit no no in the jar in the jar but you
have to fit also six of those colors in
there and do it equally let's see how
good I am with my math let's find out
what color we get when we mix all of the
colors together this guy's actually
really good at math do you remember when
you were a kid and you would play with
watercolors and you would clean your
brush off in the water yeah do you
remember what color the water became
don't say it don't say it I me it became
dirty okay oh no no you're helping me
you're helping me so
much and then the
blue and and then
finally all right that's what I mean
that's always look like dirty that's
exactly what I wanted because look if
you can see that in the light that's
solid black I don't know if I have
something that I can shine through that
that you can see even
better but yeah it's clearly W it's like
charcoal it's clearly like a brownish
color mhm wow so folks this this will
actually slay you look at this when we
mix all the colors together we get brown
we look up Genesis 2:7 and Genesis 3 God
formed Man Out of the Dust of the ground
ground and so Brown is representative as
dirt so look at this this is my
principle humanity is a central focus of
all the wonderful attributes of the
color wheel all of these colors have to
do with God's provision for us is that
beautiful is that amazing so again as a
child that was also struggling with
identity and sexuality issues I didn't
didn't think that God loved me I didn't
serve God because I didn't obey him
because I loved him I obeyed him because
I feared him when we studied these
colors with our children we're now
giving them the principle that God loves
you and that he wants to provide for you
all of these wonderful things so again
we're giving our our children not only
principles of identity and sexuality but
what's most important I think is the
fact that we are not only created by God
but Redeemed by God why because we are
the central focus of everything that he
Delights to give to us wow is that
amazing that is amazing all right folks
do now wait a minute how many colors in
our rainbow so far seven how many oh
there's six on the table but they're
seven in a real rbow that's right very
good very good so we want to discuss
what it takes to make this color here
now go ahead and fill this if you would
Mikey we want to make the indigo color
which is missing and indigo is a
combination of purple and blue so what
does it
take that's a pretty color it is pretty
unfortunately it's kind of dark here
whatever but there's a distinct
difference between these three colors
but indigo is a combination of blue
which represents the Law which is God
the father and also purple which is
royalty so isn't it interesting that
that it's a combination of a primary and
a secondary and a secondary color so
this if you'll push these two together
when I lift this we push those two
together so indigo is actually what we
call a tertiary or third level color so
wait a minute I want you to understand
that the indigo color is completely
different than all the other colors
because these are primary and secondary
colors this is a tertiary or third level
color do you think that it has a special
meaning probably do you think that God
would just throw it in there you know
it's like ah I need a filler you know
here we'll throw that in there I believe
that there's a specific meaning and
purpose behind this color and I was
praying about it and I looked in the
Bible and I go surely indigo's got to be
in there but it's not I'm a hairdresser
I'm not a Bible scholar and so I prayed
at night before I went to sleep and I
said Lord I know it means something and
I'm not figuring figuring it out so
you're gonna have to help me and I went
to sleep and so one morning not long
after that I woke up and the first thing
on my mind before I even open my eyes is
the Lord said well Mike if Indigo isn't
in the Bible or Spirit of Prophecy is
there anywhere in the Bible where blue
and purple are mentioned
together good one What sanctuary
hallelujah hallelujah I didn't know this
I had to look it up in Exodus 26 27 and
28 we find that blue and purple are
mentioned together in the sanctuary five
places in the sanctuary the high priest
robe the veil between the holy and most
holy place the veil um at the opening of
the um Sanctuary the covering over the
sanctuary also the gate around the uh
outside of the sanctuary was also had
blue and purple in it together so what
happened in the sanctuary it was all
about our Salvation that was pointing
toward Jesus pointing towards Jesus why
what does the sanctuary represent it was
representing his sacrifice sacrifice
everything that Jesus did in the
sanctuary so
Indigo represents everything that Jesus
is doing where is that Sanctuary now in
heaven in heaven in heaven so Jesus is
in the sanctuary in heaven working out
our Salvation that's the difference
between the indigo color and all of the
other colors together even though these
are important the indigo color
represents what Jesus is doing now in my
behalf to make me fit for heaven amazing
you think that's a little thing no all
right so I'm just coming together with
this so Indigo to me represents Heavenly
grace and grace is two things number one
it's unmerited favor according to
Ephesians 1:2 it means that God can't
love me less but he can't love me more
but it's also Indigo represents the
divine grace that gives me victory over
Temptation and sin so is indigo Indigo
an important color it's not my favorite
color it's absolutely my favorite color
because what happened is the indigo
represents the blue that Jesus kept the
law perfectly satisfying the
requirements of heaven but purple
represents that Jesus established the
law and died on the cross through his
blood to secure man's rescue amen is
this a little thing is this a little
thing all right so we know that in the
sanctuary there was a combination of the
red the blue and the purple together I'm
suggesting to you that the red
represents the justification when Jesus
died on that cross and rose from the
dead we were Justified that's right just
as if you hadn't done that thing that's
right that's right but the Indigo
represents the sanctification which is
the combination of the blue and purple
together which is my fitness for heaven
it's the process to help you overcome
wow
beautiful you know folks I'm telling you
I I have no idea that God would even
lead me in this direction but everything
seems to make sense and again it's not a
theological study but I think that us
using the colors that we can use the
word of God to help us to understand
what the meaning of the each color means
so so would my rainbow be incomplete
without the indigo color absolutely it's
pretty crazy that the rainbow in a
particular cultural movement right now
is missing that element right
there and doesn't want the change wants
to be celebrated in their space that
they're in without the indigo color
without the sanctification
so let me just finish this up very
clearly what happens in Revelation 101
is we know that Jesus comes to take us
home and we know that he's going to come
with a rainbow honestly I had left out
this point like in my own thoughts or
whatever but when Jesus comes there's
going to be a rainbow right so I'm
thinking to myself the Antichrist is
also going to imitate Christ's return
the Antichrist number is what six six
six which is the number of a man so it's
interesting so when the Antichrist comes
how many colors do you think are going
to be in his Rainbow Six and of all
these colors which color do you think
the Antichrist hates the most
sanctification the indigo color and so
and the six color Flag represents no but
but we're not even going to go there
with our kids but when we give them the
principles we're going to suggest to
them that if the Antichrist comes back
and he's imitating Christ and his number
is the number six which is the number of
a man Indigo represents the
sanctification which Jesus or which
Satan hates yeah doesn't it make sense
that it's possible that the Antichrist
comes with a sixc colored rainbow that
doesn't include the indigo color now we
haven't said anything about LGBT
anything and you know what and it
doesn't give us the right to be critical
or judgmental about a group of people
because remember I didn't even
understand what the rainbow meant until
just a few years ago and as I was a
member of this culture that celebrated
this rainbow I didn't create it I didn't
understand it I celebrated it but we
need to be compassionate and and and
kind and loving to individuals that do
Cate this because I think that it's not
that we're claiming back something
because that to me sounds argumentative
or competitive rather I would say this
to that community of
say what did you do with the indigo does
that make sense so rather than being you
know um good perspective that's right
that's right to basically say wait a
minute you're celebrating the rainbow
but you left out the indigo color what
where did what did you do with the
indigo and so of course nobody going to
know that you know they wouldn't know
that I didn't even know that but that
would actually open the door for a
discussion about what the indigo color
means and a Bible study about all the
Rainbow wouldn't that be beautiful way
to introduce that to somebody else but
again as a parent it's important I think
to understand what these colors mean and
so this is the the silly part that I put
up here you know you got blueberries you
got lemons bananas strawberries you know
you got kiwis you got plums which are
the indigo color oranges and even grapes
that would be the IND go color so even
at the breakfast and the dinner table
you can practice with your kids and say
hey Johnny what does you know the Kiwi
represent it's the green it's a trust
mercy and hope so these are beautiful
ways that we can celebrate the
principles then you want to go through
the through the kids room and you want
to throw away any rainbow that only has
five colors or maybe your Rainbow has 12
colors is that God's rainbow no what if
your Rainbow has pink in it that's not
God's rainbow because we know that God's
rainbow has all seven of these colors
now before your kids even hit School
you've given them a foundation of God's
principles about the seven colored
rainbow so that when they're exposed to
contemporary identities and sexualities
we've at least given our young people a
foundation of identity and sexuality as
God designed it without destroying their
innocence what do you think what do you
think I bet you the tree of knowledge of
Good and Evil the fruit was a six
colored fruit maybe so maybe so
someone's going to call you out in the
comments hary right right and we don't
want that you know and I I think that
that's why with the Children's Program
we don't ever want to address it or talk
about it because we don't want to
inflame this other group of individuals
but we do want to establish that and so
if somebody makes a comparison that's on
their own because I never said it I'm
glad that we are having this discussion
for parents and I'm glad that even this
kind of popped up and you not
approaching it from that angle not an
argumentative angle not an antagonistic
angle thank but that that you know maybe
my uh comment on that is kind of what
some people are thinking but maybe it it
needed to come out that hey maybe that's
not the best approach it's not the right
way at all in my op it can be said but
it may cause walls to go up this is a
much more gentle and loving approach to
set the truth out this is the truth of
the actual real rainbow and what a real
rainbow actually looks like aren't we
called to be harmless as doves and wise
as serpents so it might be the truth but
that's not wise to to say right
especially if you're in a situation
where you're trying to draw people into
your understanding I think it's much
more gentle to say Hey where's your
Indigo right because I love celebrating
the indigo color do you know what the
indigo color means yeah so I think
that's much more invitation and saying
well you know this is the number of a
man and it's the Antichrist and the
devil's coming with your flag you can
see how inflammatory that is and and
that is not a Christian principle amen
that does not represent what I think is
a love of we we use this example a lot
about studying the truth so you can
recognize the counterfeit how Bankers
study the real money so they can feel
instantly that this is not real so
you're studying the truth so right away
when a kid sees that pride flag they're
like that's not the right flag so so the
last day the last day after we've
discussed the rainbow and we do the
review and the boys stand up and jump
and the girls stand up and spin then we
get to what I think is the most
important part how much does God love me
this is the Capstone I believe that this
is the most most important part of what
we've discussed with our kids throughout
the week because I needed to know that
God loved me I didn't understand that I
thought that it was an accident I
thought it was a mistake I thought it
was overlooked and indifferent to God
but what we want to do on the last day
is we talk about the fact that that
before I formed you in the belly I knew
you right and Psalms 139 is the answer
to the transgender question because
Psalms 139 talks about the pursuit of
God up high or down low in darkness or
light that God is in pursuit of me and
that it doesn't matter his thoughts
towards me are countless as the Sands of
the seashore so not only does it talk
about how much he loves me but it also
talks about the fact that he protects me
his hand will lead me and guide me his
thoughts towards me are countless uh
there's too many to count and this is
really interesting because now I go
through the kids and I go did you know
that God saw my form and being
incomplete all my members are in his
book so God has like a cookbook or a
formula book and every page has a
formula of of of you Mikey and you and
you and me and so even my eyes are
recorded in his book my ears my nose my
lips my hands my fingers my toes my legs
and I don't even have to say your
genitals but you imply that when you ask
the kids are my ears in God's book
absolutely right my eyes my nose and so
we know that God knew exactly who I was
meant to be I wasn't happen stance I
wasn't a mistake everything was written
in this book and God knew exactly who I
was and I my body was not hid from you
when I was made in secret it was God
that knit my delic get inward Parts
together in my mother's womb wow what an
affirmation because I didn't know that I
thought that it was a mistake and I
think what most people don't realize as
well when they're kind of thinking about
this from a Christian perspective is the
idea of saying well God made a mistake
it's like we're now putting back on to
God that this is your problem that I'm
like this and and you know I I do
believe in broken propensities I think
there is we're working with broken
faulty equipment you know and so you
know some of these things are just a
result of sin but to ascribe that or
attribute that to God God made a mistake
is really where that logic leads but
it's a fair question because Scotty not
everyone is is had the history that you
had and I was that little kid that was
confused about who I am so the next
question and and I've been in Christian
Schools where there were little girls
that were apprehensive to stand when I
said if your little girl stand that
means that there are people like me that
are confused about who I am and again
remember God is not the author of
confusion of but of peace and so I love
Psalms 139 because it really does fully
answer that question search inside my
heart dear God if you understand that
God is loving and you understand that
God was intentional about his creation
of me if I'm confused about who I am and
it makes sense that there are children
that are confused what can I do to find
out who I am search inside my heart dear
God look inside me and know my anxious
thoughts and see if there be any wicked
way in me and Lead Me To Life
Everlasting and so I can go to God he
knows exactly who I am because I'm
recorded in his book before the earth
was formed I was created he knew all of
the wonderful attributes that he was
going to Lavish me with we've
established the fact that God loves us
and so how beautiful I will praise you
in verse 14 for I am fearfully and
wonderfully made if I'm confused about
who I am I don't have to worry about
what you think of who I am I can go to
God and say Lord will you remind me who
you made me to be and that God doesn't
make mistakes right so it was Jesus who
made each one of us and I think this is
a perfect way to end our 5-day study
about God's identity and sexuality
without destroying their innocence
without bringing in contemporary themes
and identities now we've given our
children a foundation and also told them
about the fact that all of this was
based on the love of Jesus Christ and
that was the motivation for how he made
each one of us amen beautiful you you
don't need the the um overwhelming you
know mechanics of how this works your
simple illustration is like yeah that's
right that's how God made that and kids
respond like that they're smarter than
we give them and they will make those
applications so I really appreciate your
approach in just saying you know let's
talk about the truth this is the truth
of the matter and those kids man their
brains are working I mean I remember my
kids always shocking me with like what
you you're fully comprehending this I
mean that's a pretty complex um you know
idea to really grasp on to but I I
believe we sort of think that kids are
not quite as as fast as we think they
are and they're picking up on these
these these things so so Scotty this is
the basic you start off with this with
your preschoolers and then as your kids
get older and they start asking some
difficult questions well mommy there was
a little boy that says his name is is
Alice you know like what is that about
so when a child opens up those questions
I believe that we have to be honest and
we we can't shame our kids and say oh
don't talk about that that's disgusting
that's horrible instead to take it at
face value go back to the principles and
say well how did God make this child you
know to be and how do you think that God
sees that encourage dialogue encourage
conversation reestablish again the
principle and as your children get older
you've already given them the foundation
they're going to need more information
you're going to eventually have to talk
about the sixc colored flag and the
group of people that celebrate that but
now you can at least do it in an
environment where they have a foundation
and you can take them to the next level
as they realize ah I learned about that
when I was a kid and this is the next
step and the next step so we don't want
to we don't want to candy coat or hide
anything about what the world's doing
but we certainly don't want to give our
children more than what they're capable
of but as they progress if they have
this as a foundation then those next
questions can take them to the next
level understanding that there are
transgender people there are people that
are inex there are people that are
confused you know but they're not ready
to learn that at four and five but but
when they are and if they can get an
honest answer from a parent without
feeling rejected or judged or
scrutinized then what's happening is
you're now a valuable source of
information I know I can go to my dad
and he's going to give me the truth he's
not going to make me feel bad if I feel
like I'm a girl trapped in a boy's body
he's going to give me the truth and the
foundation so that you are still the
source of information rather than well
you know I can't trust him I'll go to my
friends in school or I'll go to Tik Tok
to find out who I am do you see the
difference in that love it I love it I
absolutely love the approach you guys
got any final questions for Mike no this
is amazing is this actually there's a
question is this available for people to
get somehow uh we're working on a
resource to put it together so that we
can have an illustrated book that
parents can go through with their
children and and we want to make it
different levels so we want a level for
like um you know grade school children
and then we want to start getting into
high school and to like older yeah young
adults yeah I just want to drop a plug
here for our podcast for two reasons one
you talked about the temple
sanctuary in season 1 of the podcast
there's an episode called what the Old
Testament Tabernacle has to do with your
salvation literally explains everything
and why we believe that Jesus is
currently in heaven in the new sanctuary
and in season two that we're working on
everyone I actually spoke with Michael
kuchi and we did an episode recording on
uh can a Christian be LT btq plus that's
coming out in season 2 awesome awesome
well thank you so much Michael always a
pleasure to have you on here and we're
going to be praying for you cuz I know
the devil does not like the truth and
and you're pulling the wool back and
showing and revealing God's real true
intention with giving us this beautiful
planet that we live on and and this this
beautiful illustration that that really
I mean I I learned something see this
isn't just for kids I love this and uh
we hope you guys were blessed out there
thank you guys for tuning in and
watching LED live and this is Michael
kuchi if you haven't checked out his
channel you can go to coming out
ministries.org so Michael is in the
throws of raising money for his first
building that coming out Ministries will
actually have to call home so we're
excited about that we went through that
process and our generous donors uh
helped us get this building that you're
seeing us in so um we know what that
process is like and we're going to be
praying for you but if you feel
impressed to donate helping Mike good
out there and teach the truth about some
of these things to our kids then please
consider donating to coming out
Ministries as well give this video a
thumbs up like it and if you know some
parents or children that would be very
impacted by this kind of a message
please share that with them and uh as
always if you want to support our work
so that we can have more guests on like
Michael and discuss more topics like
this then please consider giving us a uh
uh end of the year donation as well and
we would thank you guys so much and we
do thank you for helping us do this work
we feel blessed we'll hope you to see
you next time God
bless it's proven that people remember
things that they see more than what they
hear lightwear believes best way to
share your witness is to wear your
witness lightwear has all kinds of
graphic te's that are a great attention
grabbing way to share the gospel so head
on over to lightwear do shop and check
out all the cool graphic te's what do
you want people to remember when they
see
[Music]
you hey subscribe to
stud if you want to learn Spanish a
great way will be watching our videos
for practice do you have questions about
the Bible that you've been struggling to
find the answers for video Bible study
or VBS for short is a YouTube channel
that answers your Bible questions in 5
minutes or less check out these easy to
understand comprehensive videos talking
about everything from what happens when
you die to why does God allow suffering
make it your goal to deepen your
relationship with Christ this year and
subscribe to video bible study on
YouTube to help you along your
[Music]
journey